alright well I hope you're enjoying the
conference so far my name is not Michael
leaf those of you looking at your
schedule Michael Lee my boss has a
newborn baby boy and so he couldn't be
here so I'm here in his stead my name is
Arielle man down a fufu I'm a data
scientist at the data incubator which is
a data science training organization and
we run a fellowship program that takes
PhD students in analytical fields and
runs them through a two-month boot camp
to get them up to speed on what they
need to be effective data scientists or
at least start out being effective data
scientists and we also do a bunch of
corporate training type stuff as well
and my my interest personally lie mostly
in machine learning human behavior type
stuff things like that so unfortunately
i don't have michael's NLP talk so if
you're here only for the NLP I won't be
in I won't be offended if you leave what
I do have for you is a couple projects
we put together recently that highlights
a kind of practical workflows for
machine learning and Python so not just
you know the regression but all the
stuff that comes before and after the
regression to think through an entire
kind of end-to-end project and I
actually have two pretty interesting
ones one is a recommendation engine for
movies and the other is anomaly
detection from time series data so my
plan is kind of to go through these
using Jupiter notebooks there if you
want to follow along you can go to our
github it's just github.com / the data
incubator then we have a public repo
called PI data 2016 and you can clone
that and follow the readme instructions
for
you know if you have condo already will
be very easy to get the environment
setup if not you know do your package
management stuff and this will also be
available afterwards so there's no rush
since there's only 45 minutes or now 40
minutes I'm mostly going to be talking
at a pretty high level and we can go
back and check out the code later on so
if that sounds good to people some
scattered nods some people looking
forward to lunch alright so how many
people in here have done machine
learning in Python before Oh excellent
so they weren't lying when they said
this is an intermediate talk great so we
won't have to delve too deep into all
the way know from first principles what
we're doing and unfortunately they're
not going to be a ton of surprises
because I ran a lot of these cells
beforehand but yeah let's just show you
what we did
so recommendation engines are pretty
it's pretty broad what you mean by that
there's many different ways to build a
recommendation engine many different
approaches you can take and we wanted to
just highlight just the way that we
thought about approaching a very simple
recommendation problem using both
content-based and collaborative rating
and the mood today is that we're going
to be using is this movie lens ten
million data set which is publicly
available and you can go download it
yourself and we have some nice piece of
code here just to check point to make
sure that we don't download it every
time please just you know tell me if you
need me to slow down or anything so we
have this data file and we basically do
some initial parsing cleaning up of the
data so we're going to take this movie
movies data for sorry movies file and
parse it into a panda with categories
title and year
so we can see that different movies are
organized into different categories we
also have tags so these are tags which
users have clicked on to each movie and
we also have ratings so we have user ID
rating and movie ID
clip so far so standard so the first
thing you might want to try is a Content
modeling approach you know if a user
likes adventure movies we should
recommend more adventure movies to them
but instead of just saying adventure or
some other category we can treat the
problem a little bit more
comprehensively and represent the
categories feature as a one hot encoded
matrix of all of the categories right so
now instead of saying adventure equals
one drama equals to comet equals three
we'll just treat category as a Moore's
onra as a categorical variable and we
will use this scikit-learn ability to
write custom classes to just easily
transform our categories our list of
categories into dictionaries or now we
have a key which is the category and we
have a one and then if we pass this
through a dick vector Iser which is
something if you did come here for NLP
you'll be very used to then what will
get out is a sparse matrix with every
movie and what categories it has as ones
and the categories were not science that
movie as zero
so for more beginning audiences I like
to spend a lot of time here and talk
about how great it is that we have this
infrastructure inside he'll learn to
build custom stuff and how it would be a
lot more difficult if we only had to
pick and choose from the available
options that were given to us and I
think a lot of the know go into some
rant about python vs are and how
important you know how important it is
to have that infrastructure available to
you but I think you're all on board from
the start so to use that infrastructure
also take advantage of this pipeline so
if you guys have done machine learning
and Python you've probably used the
scikit-learn pipe pipeline which is a
really neat way to sequentially pass
inputs through transformers and then
ultimately through an estimator if you
want so in this case our pipeline is
just going to be our [ __ ] encoder
which we wrote will pass it apply that
to the categories and then we'll
vectorize the result of that and so this
is just going to be a transformer
pipeline where we now have features and
if you can yeah so features is now a
sparse matrix
alright everybody with me so far yeah
okay so how do we approach this problem
now of finding other movies that are
like the ones that we have our when or
look like the ones that we care about we
have a way to describe a movie we have
this feature of all the categories in
the sparge may strip the sparse matrix
and one simple approach to take is just
nearest neighbors so if you're not
familiar with the k-nearest neighbors
algorithm we're basically going to take
our training set our training set here
is represented as the red triangles and
the blue squares and when we see a new
data point that we want to classify and
here it's represented as green we will
just look at all of the nearest other
observations in our feature space and so
in this example classification problem
we would classify this green dot as part
of the red triangle class because the
nearest neighbors in the feature space
were a red triangles and it's a fairly
extensible algorithm you can think about
doing things like waiting the vote of
each nearest neighbor based on how far
it is right so think data points that
are very close have a stronger vote then
points at your farther away you can also
do things like regression using this
algorithm you just take the average of
all the nearest neighbors instead of
some kind of vote for classification
and there's also different distance
metric metrics you can use so here I'm
just thinking very abstractly you have
some very high dimensional feature space
and we're basically going to use the
Euclidean distance to measure the
difference between these two vectors in
feature space and determine the nearest
what is nearest based on that metric but
if you want to get into it you know you
can abstract this up to the Minkowski
distance which is another degree of
freedom you can play with and the
interesting thing about nearest
neighbors is it actually does do
something during the fit-step which you
might not believe it has to do the
fit-step is actually pretty important
for the algorithm to partition the
training set in a way that it knows
what's close to which data points are
close to each other if you can imagine
what would happen if you had no
information about your training set when
you try to run a prediction your
computer would start trying to calculate
distances from that new data point to
like every other data points in your
training set which would be many many
many data points it's a lot of
computation so what these algorithms do
in scikit-learn is implemented a couple
different methods for doing this is
identify regions of your feature space
which are distinct from other regions so
that if I want to find the closest point
to this green dot I know not to start
with the stuff out here and the edges I
know to start with stuff in the same
region and that's a very hand-wave way
of describing it but that's another
degree of freedom you have to play with
ok so that's k-nearest neighbors and
we're just going to use this for movies
we're going to say we have some feature
space which somehow represents the
categories that the movies have so we're
going to look at for any given movie
what are the closest neighbors that
movie in category space
so we'll pick up two movies for test
cases Toy Story and dr. strangelove
because they're kind of stuff different
kinds of challenges and you can see here
what this looks like in the original
data frame and here's a bit of code that
will just extract out the distances and
the indices in the data frame for for
the nearest neighbors so you can see
that we have instantiated nearest
neighbors up here with n neighbors
equals 20 so we're looking for the 20
nearest neighbors and we fit this as
well
so now we're going to get out a list of
20 distances and indices and we're just
going to look at the indices in the
original data frame to pick out what are
these nearest neighbors actually and so
for toy story we see things like kiki's
delivery service you know ants Emperor's
New Groove toy story 2 so this does
pretty well it's not picking out Pixar
movies per se but it's picking out
similar kinds of things but this kind of
limitation is a little bit more
appearance when we're looking at dr.
Strangelove because we get a lot of
comedy war movies but not a lot of them
are similar to like the message of dr.
Strangelove so we might want to give
this model a little bit more information
one next thing we could try is the tag
data so we have a lot more information
the user applied tags again this is what
the tag data frame looks like so we're
just going to do the naive thing we're
going to one hot encode these tags
create features that associate with each
movie ID and and do the same kind of
process and what that looks like is
well this is just showing you some tags
I don't need to do this what that looks
like is we're going to just do a join
between all the tags of a movie and the
movie data frame which we already have
so now we have in the same data frame
categories and tag and pandas makes this
really easy to do
and then we'll use the same kind of
pipeline and this is the kind of thing
which gets to be really fun when you're
working with scikit-learn is that now
you have multiple pipelines for
different kinds of features I can have
one set of processing steps four
categories a different set of processing
steps for tags which here are called cat
pipe and tag pipe and then I can use a
feature Union to combine both of those
resultant feature matrices into one big
feature matrix which I pass into an
estimator so you can imagine that if
you're working with data which is not
just numeric but you have text data you
have categorical data you have all sorts
of different things time data you can
process all of those separately using
separate pipelines and then use feature
Union to combine them and it's really
this combination of like sequential
processing and parallel processing which
means you can build like any kind of
Tinkertoy structure you want to with
scikit-learn and makes it very very
powerful
so we're just doing the same thing we're
doing before we're just using this
feature you need to organize it and then
when we fit these features we see now
that we have over 16,000 columns so the
tags there are a lot more different
unique tags and there were categories so
now our matrix has a lot more columns in
it
so we do the same thing we train nearest
neighbors and we look for 20 nearest
neighbors and we look at what's the
model has said are the closest things to
toy story and it has indeed figured out
that the closest thing to a story's toy
story 2 now but the other ones are maybe
even a little less obvious this is the
one with the squirrel in the airplane I
think Digimon so it's not really that
great dr. Strangelove is pretty similar
yeah question how long did that take do
yeah it takes we can write it I can
actually run all the cells above above
this it takes less than a minute
so let's start here run all the cells
above this
it's going to take some time to to run
these first cells like parts through all
of the data and stuff like that
what
so I'll come back and run that cell once
it's once I see the little circle has
done processing
okay so yeah it's not that great still
and we think that the reason is that oh
there we go we think that the reason is
that the tag space is so large there's a
lot of just empty to empty data right so
we have so many unique tags but most
movies don't have a lot of tags so that
means that if we have a lot of these
feature columns which are all just like
very little information like there's no
tags here then they get marked in the
nearest neighbors as similar to other
movies which have like no tags and if
you think about nearest neighbors doing
this Euclidean distance you know the
feature column for tag funniest movies
is given the same importance as the
feature column for the tow manse
category so we've kind of maybe even
diluted the predictive power of our
model from before okay so where were we
10
18 okay so now we can train this nearest
neighbors model and that's it I guess
when it was less than a minute it was
actually stuck on a different cell
I'll try to keep running them as I go so
this is a pretty common problem that we
come across when we're trying to do
stuff is we have a lot of information
but it may not all be relevant or it may
not be organized in a way that lets the
model easily distinguish between what we
care about so in this case we have like
16,000 columns where we're really trying
to capture ideas where's are probably
less than 16,000 ideas and that's a good
indication that you might want to do
dimensionality reduction so this is
something which in our fellowship people
often you know when we go through this
stuff we want people ask you know what
when do you do this and the answer is
whenever you think that this kind of
situation is happening so for those of
you haven't used dimensionality
reduction what we're essentially
attempting to do is take something like
the map on the left and change it into
the map on the right where we maintain
as much of the usability of the map as
possible so for example if I want to get
around DC I probably don't need that
extra dimension of topological data and
we're going to see that not only does
that make the model run faster because
as you can see this ends up compressing
your data set and making it faster to
process but it can also make the map
look cleaner right and to the model what
this means is that instead of these
sixteen thousand columns of largely
croft now we have fewer columns where
each column is maybe more meaningful so
we're going to use
we're going to use sbd to do the
singular value decomposition there are
many different ways to approach this
problem a lot of them involve matrix
decomposition which not to go into the
math too much but we're essentially
going to take our feature matrix to look
at how all those features play out in
the feature space and figure out the
directions in that feature space where
those features very the most so if we
look at this blob in two-dimensional
space we have one feature which is X and
the other feature which is why but
actually there's better directions in
this feature space to capture most of
the variance of the data for example
this one and this one and in fact what
we can do is identify all of those all
of those you know principal components
if we were doing PCA or I ghen vectors
if we're just doing SVD and then just
keep the most important ones so for
example I could just keep this one long
vector and drop the short one now my
feature space would not be
two-dimensional it would be one
dimension will just be a line but there
would still be a fair bit of variance in
my data along that line so I would lose
some information but maybe not all the
important information
and so there's a lot of tuning that goes
into this as well not just in the choice
of how many principal components are
most important directions of variance
you want to keep but also like which
method you want to use so I keep going
thinking about text data because this is
suppose to be an NLP talk if you're
doing text data you have counts you
really don't expect those counts that
ever be negative and so it might be more
appropriate to do non-negative matrix
factorization instead of something like
this then a non-negative matrix
factorization your resulting feature
columns are going to be guaranteed to be
positive values so in any case we do
this dimensionality reduction and we're
going to choose 100 arbitrarily not
arbitrarily but it was pretty much a
guest in checked and we'll just dump
that into our pipeline so this is really
easy
we don't have to do this on our category
pipeline we just have we can apply it's
just the tag pipeline so i said i would
keep running these cells oh boy let's
just try running this one
so now we have a sparse matrix with 120
columns right so we specified 100
principal compensable components but the
most important directions of our tag
feature space and then we still have the
20 from the category feature space so we
do the same exact thing we fit nearest
neighbors and look at the results this
time we see a lot of disney movies it
actually looks like it's cleaned it up
quite a bit and if we look at dr.
Strangelove we actually get more
relevant things like the great dictator
or mash meaning of life arguably a full
metal jacket things like that and when
you do this SVD or this dimensionality
reduction if you remember that oval
we've kind of instead of features X and
Y now we have some new feature that's
kind of a mixture of x and y and this
can be a problem for explicable ax t
right because you don't want to tell
your boss I started with the number of
rooms in the house and the square
footage but now my model is looking at a
feature that's like room footage or
something like that some mixture of the
two so we can actually look at what the
new what these new dimensions of the SVD
are comprised of and we can just extract
that out of the pipeline very easily so
we're just going to print out the top 10
for each one of these directions and
there's a lot of nudity in a lot of
these directions but you can if you go
through this see certain ideas that are
correlated together
so like here's 70 millimeter quirky
satirical irrelevant humorous disturbing
here's IMDB top 250 along with national
film registry kind of makes sense a lot
of times that we see based on a book
we'll also see the other tag like
adapted from books like based on a book
adapted from book stylized based on book
so it's like figuring out that there are
some kind of you know instead of just
having each one of these tags as a
separate feature there are ideas right
this whole deal is that whole thing was
to get fewer ideas out of this 16,000
features all right so how am i doing on
time it's [ __ ] tough team okay well
we might just stick with recommendation
then so so far we're like pretty pleased
with this and this is like a good
starting point but you can obviously do
a lot more so we want to do a lot more
we can do a good job of suggesting
movies that are similar to an existing
movie now with this nearest neighbors
technique and sometimes that's all you
need if you see a user buying Toy Story
you can recommend toy story 2 but we
often want to suggest movies to a user
before we know what they're buying right
so one approach would be to calculate an
average movie that that user enjoyed and
then you use nearest neighbors to find
all the related movies to that average
movie so what that looks like is we'll
just get the ratings data frame here
and we'll look at one particular user
this guy seems to like horror movies and
then we'll just compute a weighted
average so all we're really doing is
taking all of these taking all of these
movies and averaging them out and if we
then go into our already trained nearest
neighbors model and then pass in the
observation for this weighted average
movie we'll see what the nearest
neighbors are to that point so we just
taken that green point instead of the
green points being toy story now with
some average of all the movies that that
user liked before that that user rated
and so you can see that there are a lot
of horror movies that are nearby which
makes sense so do you then filter out
visitors artists you know if this is a
business application yeah you might
choose
well this whole bunch of of things do
you know you sometimes you don't want to
recommend the most obvious thing but you
want to recommend something a little bit
in a new direction to try and give them
something that they might not have seen
yet right or something that they might
have explored yet and that actually is a
good segue into the next part which is
collaborative and we could use this to
you know to find items similar to what a
user already likes but we often want to
use the fact that we have many other
users in our system to help and what the
idea behind this is that if we can find
a user that's similar to our target user
and we know what that user liked then we
can make recommendations based on that
for what our current user is going to
like and to do that we can still use
nearest neighbors except instead of
figuring out what are the closest movies
to any given movie based on these
features like category and tag we'll
figure out what are the nearest users to
any given user based on how they rated
movies so we'll assume that to users are
similar if they've rated movies
similarly so here all we're doing is
we're grouping by user ID and we're
making into a dictionary all of these
user ratings and then we're going to
pass that into dick vector Iser so now
we have and this might take a while to
now we have
like a whole bunch of users and for each
user we have like a whole bunch of
information about movies and how they
were rated by that user Victor
vectorized into a sparse matrix and this
is a point where we can actually do
something a little clever and realize
that when we're doing nearest neighbors
before we be using the euclidean
distance right so you have two points in
this feature space you see how far apart
they are basically using a straight line
method but for users it makes a little
bit more sense to use a cosine metric in
other words we only want to know the
angle between the vectors and feature
space this is because some users just
tend to rate movies on different scales
and other users right some user might
rate things fives and fours and rarely
give a one another user might rate
things one two three four five and those
things are going to have different
magnitudes in this feature space so we
don't want that to necessarily relate in
a different distance so we'll just look
at the angle between these vectors
and that's as simple as just passing in
metric equals cosine to the algorithm so
there we go and now we can look at
and this is a little dense but
essentially what we're going to do here
is take that model that we just fit
we're going to get the uid here is the
user ID of this horror user we're
looking at and we're going to plug his
part of the feature matrix into
k-nearest neighbors so now we're going
to get out all of the elements of this
user rating data frame which are the
closest to to this user and it turns out
that if we filter out this DF ratings
data frame by user ID by the ones that
are actually in the nearest neighbors we
can then group by title and look at the
rating and so what this is doing is
giving us a whole bunch of movie titles
and all the different ratings for all
the people who are considered neighbors
of that user by this cosine metric and
it turns out that there's 367 elements
in this group so what this looks like is
something like this if we organized by
the average right we look at the average
rating for each one of these movies we
see that you know there was a user
considered similar to our target user
who rated Dracula 5 stars
the problem with using the average is
that the top of the average list is
always five when one person has rated
that movie 5 and nobody else has rated
that movie so it makes it a bit of a
problem because now the most popular
movies by this metric and we should
recommend are ones that have only been
rated once so we could try doing
something like summing up all of the
ratings and if we do that we get
something that looks like this but now
jaws is at the top because a lot of
people have seen jaws a lot of people
have rated jaws so all those ratings add
up and now the most popular movies are
at the top and if there's one really
cool horror movie that only three people
have rated like that's not going to beat
a mediocre movie that everybody's seen
so to solve this problem we can do
something called Bayesian smoothing and
statistically what we're doing is we're
introducing a prior and then formulating
a posterior estimate of the rating
taking into account both the prior and
the new information from our from our
processing thank you what this really is
saying is that if a movie has only been
rated once that obviously is not going
to be as as relevant on our scheme as a
movie that's been rated a bunch of times
but we can artificially give counts to
movies so that we don't have as much as
extreme of a problem so instead of
saying that a movie like the one we saw
at the very top Dracula has only been
seen once and it's mean is five
will say well give a few artificial
counts to Dracula will say every movie
starts with like five counts five
reviews and they're all three stars and
so what that will do is it will lessen
the difference between movies which have
only been rated once in movies which
have been rated the Lots because we've
artificially added counts to the low end
and it will mean that instead of having
Dracula rated at five it's now rated
higher than three but not like absurdly
higher than three because there was only
one person who rated it so this kind of
smoothing is very common especially
where you have things that only occur a
few times like in restaurant reviews you
might only get the name of a certain
dish once or twice but you don't want
that to be overshadowed by like the more
popular dishes so this is also something
that you can play around with in tune
you can tune both mu which is what we're
calling here the the mean we're in the
rank ease movies with few reviews start
to appear and here we're just saying
they should appear in the middle of the
ranking and then you can control n which
is this artificial number of counts
which were adding in other words how
confident are we that a movie which
hasn't been reviewed much should be
about average
so this idea is no it's pretty popular I
see it a lot so we can easily build this
function here called base some and we'll
just dump that into our ratings group
this is our group I object and I will
aggregate by base some and if we look at
what we get out so we still have jaws at
the top but we also see things which
which weren't there before like
Ghostbusters and ghostbusters isn't even
really a horror movie but it was rated
very highly by some of his neighbors and
so it made it in a lot higher up the
list
and there are a lot of ways to do cross
validation I haven't talked a lot about
cross validation yet but I've just
thrown all these parameters that you can
tune and not told you how to tune them
but one way to tune Beijing smoothing is
to look at how your list changes as you
change these parameters if you have a
list of the top 10 movies and you change
the parameters and the list is tech 10
completely different movies then you
probably are you have not quite
converged like a stable set of
parameters but if you change your
Beijing smoothing parameter and the top
10 list of movies doesn't change at all
then it means you're probably pretty
stable and you can like make a little
graph and say I'm I want to wait until
the top 10 movies changes by less than
ten percent with each iteration of the
smoothing parameter or something like
that and use that as I'm kinda makeshift
cross-validation so when you're playing
around with this code on your own some
fun things to do you can look at the
effect of different just different
distance metrics on the recommendations
which I kind of alluded to before you
can also add in the year of the movie
this is something which is also a little
tricky because is it true that a user
who likes movies from 1970 will like
movies from 1971 and what about nineteen
eighty and if it's a continuous variable
does it scale continuously or should
each year be its own category is there a
way to find compromise between these two
things like maybe you take your ranges
as categories so there's a lot of
different options that you can dry out
and there's a little note here that just
says yaky nearest neighbor is a distance
measure so you have to be very careful
about scaling all your data before you
calculate the distance otherwise larger
years are just going to be farther apart
than smaller years just naturally and
there's another big thing which we have
left out of this analysis which is that
we consider not reviewing a movie at all
to be less of recommendation than
scoring at a one so maybe we should
build in something that's like if a
movie has not been rated at all it
counts as a three or something like that
that might give us a little bit of a
better result okay so I know I'm zooming
through this but i want to show you last
part which is regression often the first
thing we do is a first thing we learn is
data scientists regression but the last
thing we're going to do here we've
developed the several ways to recommend
movies to a user but the fact is most
most users have not rated most movies
right you rate some small subset of the
movies there's many more movies that you
haven't rated and what that means is
that we a don't have a ton of data about
how users will react to a whole bunch of
the rest of the movies and B is that a
sign that the user doesn't like those
movies are that they just haven't seen
them yet so this is where modeling comes
in where we want to extrapolate from
what we know to what we don't know and
we don't really know what a user is
going to rate a movie that they haven't
rated but we can try to guess and
there's going to be two points to this
one is that if we guess what their
ratings are going to be we can then feed
those guesses back into the analysis
we've done before and get perhaps better
information about like the best average
movie that is going to be what they like
or whatever but also we can just use a
regression to to predict you know maybe
you've done your analysis the first
point you've come oh i think i should
recommend this one
let's see what the regression model
thinks they're going to score this one
so as you are probably well aware we can
do a train test splits and we're going
to measure performance with root mean
squared error so I'll skip through that
and we're going to basically build a
model that has three components at the
baseline one is the the average of all
ratings the other is the difference
between for a specific user between the
average of their ratings in the average
of everybody's ratings so if I tend to
rate things fours and fives I want the
model to be able to pick up on that as
opposed to someone who rates things ones
and twos and then I'll also have a term
for the difference between a movies
average rating and the average rating
for everything so if a movie is very
good I want to have a term that lets the
model pick up on that as opposed to just
always recommending me good movies
because they're good I want the model to
learn that good movies are good and bad
knees are bad but what may be relevant
for the user is not just the the raw
quality of the movie
and if you're into like machine learning
competitions and stuff like that you
know netflix has this grand prize and it
turns out that the winners of that
Netflix grand prize most of their
performance came from this baseline
model they made some improvements with
the details of the algorithms and stuff
like that but the vast majority of the
work is done by the spaceline model what
that means is that it pays to think
about the baseline model a little bit I
mean it's easy to get sucked into
thinking about parameters and
optimization and tuning and stuff but
it's often important to think about your
original assumptions as well so all we
really need to do to train this is to
one hot encode the users in the movies
and run linear regression so that's
exactly what we do we take our handy
dick tizer custom class and we apply it
to user IDs we apply it to movie IDs
so we do a feature union to combine them
and then we just run linear regression
and we'll define some function here to
measure root mean squared error
dude so well as a baseline to calibrate
what we should expect we'll just take a
mean model right well just take a model
that predicts the average for everything
and that turns out to have root mean
squared error a little bit over one our
baseline model with which doesn't seem
to have I forgot to run us so
this one
I may have just forgotten to run the
train to the winner on this one no no
you come to
on this one this is one can be 3x I oh
thank you so we do a little bit better
about twenty percent better and when we
look at how we do on the training sets
it's actually substantially different
and that's kind of an indication that
there's a big difference between our
training performance and our test
performance which indicates that we
probably are over fitting and if we look
at the number of coefficients we have
over 11,000 you can see we're kind of in
the same boat that we were in before
okay so what we can do is we could
so I'm just going to wrap up here so we
could do something similar to what we
did before it turns out handily that
regularization will do almost as good of
a job because if we add regularization
to this model then it actually gives us
a term very similar to this bayesian
smoothing term and so we can just add
regularization find this regulation
parameter with grid search and and then
rerun to training and we'll actually do
somewhat better so this has just been an
example of I think mostly thought
process you have some data set about
movies we wanted to build a
recommendation engine but you can see
that it various steps on the way there's
things you have to think about things
which may trip you up things which if
you ignore them are going to scare your
results and these are the things that
keep data scientists employed right
because otherwise a computer could just
do this by itself so I hope that you at
least get a little something about how
to think how we thought about this and
maybe that helps you
again the github page is up there if you
want to play around at this code
yourself there's another project I
didn't have time for which is anomaly
detection of time series data where we D
trend City Bike Share ridership data to
make it stationary as possible and then
basically to use a z-score to find
anomaly dates in the bike ridership
program and if you go through that
you'll see that you can actually pull
out like days where the brightest ship
program was closed due to software
malfunctions or it was a particularly
nice day in New York things like that
and that also has like a lot of business
implications so I will happily take any
questions if not you're free to go to
lunch